الهجوم الذي استمر ساعتين هو الاحدث على
صوامع الحبوب ومنشات الموانئ الاوكرانيه
منذ يوليو تموز الماضي وهو تاريخ انسحاب
روسيا من اتفاق كان يسمح بتصدير الامن
للحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر البحر
الاسود استهدف العدو البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ والحدود لنهر الدانوب اصيب اثنان
من سائقي الشاحنات جراء الهجوم ولحقت
اضرار بصوامع الحبوب وبمب اداريه ومركبات
شحن القوات الروسيه باتت تستهدف بانتظام
هذه المنطقه الواقعه في جنوب اوكرانيا
والمطل على البحر الاسود ولم تعد تبالي
بنتائج تدمير هذه المنشات الحيويه التي
تشكل منفذا لتصدير الحبوب روسيا كانت قد
وافقت على التوقيع مع اوكرانيا في يوليو
2022 على اتفاقيه دوليه تحت رعايه تركيا
والامم المتحده لسماح بتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود وذلك لمواجهه
ضغوط المجتمع الدولي والمخاطر التي يشكلها
الحصار على الامن الغذائي العالمي وفي عام
واحد تمكن ما يقرب من 33 مليون طن من
الحبوب من مغادره موانئ اوديسا وتشون مورس
ويزني مما ادى الى تجنب ازمه الغذاء التي
كانت تهدد العديد من البلدان في افريقيا
ومنطقه البحر الابيض المتوسط ميناء
اسماعيل كان قد استهدف في اغسطس بمسيرات
روسيه وكان قد اثار استهدافه انتقادات
غربيه حيث اتهمت فرنسا والاتحاد الاوروبي
روسيا بتعريض الامن الغذائي العالمي للخطر
على نحو متعمد من خلال تدمير بنى تحتيه
اساسيه لتصدير الحبوب